[Musique]
nancy asselin et ses trois amis sont
authentiques beauceronne elle planifie
déjà leur troisième voyage ensemble
alors mesdames bienvenue super heureuse
de vous accueillir chez moi chez madame
germaine dans ma maison où l'un dès que
les conditions sanitaires le permettent
c'est décidé s envole ensemble vers leur
prochaine destination
ce soir vous avez choisi de partir à
jarry c'est ici à lévis que se préparent
déjà leur périple avec un rouleau la
globe trotteuse culinaire alias madame
germaine greu savoir des grandes tablées
beaucoup de gens tout le monde était
bienvenue donc ça a été mon inspiration
pour le premier venu que j'ai passionnés
de bouffées de voyage anne roux nous
offre des ateliers pour faire découvrir
la cuisine des pays où elle a longuement
séjourné à lorsqu'on enfin c'est pas un
cours de cuisine technique c'est
vraiment plus une expérience culinaire
culturel
quand je leur voyage sur reçu dans les
maisons c'est la même chose ici je
reçois déjà chez moi je talent et vivent
plusieurs mois dans plusieurs endroits
donc que ce soit en chaîne que ce soit
cameron que ce soit au pérou j'ai fait
plusieurs pays
mais un jour d'années j'étais allé
tellement saoul bas c'est comme ma
deuxième maison
j'ai toutes mes familles à aller voir du
nord au sud puis je fais mon trajet puis
voilà
il ya énormément à voir c'est un pays
d'histoire la jordanie si chère à anne
rouleau est un pays du moyen-orient
la cuisine est en grande partie
d'origine bédouine
ces nomades du désert une cuisine à base
de riz de viande et des pis je pensais
par femme que les épices en général sont
très importants pour cette cuisine et
les cuisines du monde l'aurait rangèrent
hyman saïfi a grandi en jordanie
c'est un importateur et un artisan des
pis les 4e génération ça recommence avec
mon arrière grand père mon grand père
mon père est aujourd'hui c'est moi les
rênes donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui se retrouvent dans le sens de notre
vie
donc aujourd'hui on fait nos propres
mélanges confirmé les épices il faut que
le goût soit authentique tout ce que je
veux c'est répliqué un peu le même
feeling les mêmes émotions qu'on vit
quand on mange la nourriture dans le
camp mais je vais vous montrer comment
faire un mélange des acteurs
traditionnels de la jordanie le zaatar
c'est ce mélange d'épicés et d'herbes du
moyen-orient que les voyages eux
s'apprêtent à découvrir en amuse bouche
avec leurs propres pepita maison donc
est un essai pour commencer on a du
talent jordanien donc ça c'est le vin
grézian majeur dans le produit et le
temps jordanien diffèrent d autant
qu'ils se retrouvent dans nos pays
surtout à cause de la terre et des
minéraux qui se trouvent dans cette
région deux autres ingrédients qui
composent le zaatar les sésames route si
celle de mr des épices secrète et le
sumak dessus mais qu'en pense à ça vient
de nos petits fruits rouges des
vinaigriers au québec on les utilise pas
vraiment mais la bosse et un ep j'ai
envie de dire qui est très populaire qui
ajoute une bonne acidité
voici ma mère rim qui fait partie de mon
inspiration dans la création de mes
recettes on peut manger les artères de
plusieurs façons dont une celle trempé
mais sinon on peut le mélange est
directement avec de l'huile d'olive et
l'utiliser comme un genre de spreads sur
du pain pita islamo décline donc qu'ils
allaient prendre ce train de frapper un
peu dans l'huile ensuite un peu dans un
attentat au colis supplément des comme
ça
les attend en fait on peut le mettre sur
plein de choses moi j'en mets sur-mesure
matin jamais sur mes pizzas jamais dans
mes salades
prochaine étape on va commencer la base
pour le manceau
comme plat de résistance lemay national
jordanien le monde ça c'est le mais le
plus typique de la jordanie c'est une
fierté pour les jordaniens
si on est reçu normalement c'est le plan
qui vont nous faire d'emblée parce que
c'est le plat de réception la mannshaft
là c'est vraiment jordanien bédouins
donc du poulet ou de l'agneau moi
j'utilise le poulet sur du riz du maïs a
foulé un sacrilège selon amman
une chanson drôle qui a breath cette
question là puisqu'il dit que le vrai
message il fait à lannion ne fait pas le
vent sa foulée la chanter pour cuisiner
le médecin il faut jongler avec les
épices la viande est entre autres
parfumé de cardamome de clous de girofle
et de cannelle les pièces sont déposés
sur un lit de riz au curcuma l'instant
foulée on veut que ces documents ils
permettront les pilons soit l'intérieur
extérieur passé de faire un beau soleil
et avec ça une sauce à base de hyogo de
cherves fort mais pas tout le bouillon
faut que ça reste secret du bourg de
chèvre en jordanie utilisent déjà me dit
que ça s'appelle donc c'est à hyogo de
chefs qui est séché en quelque sorte non
peut pas ici c'est pas disponible donc
j'utilise le yo gourd de cherves ya
moyen de faire cette source l'homme
qu'elle soit aussi j'en veux dire aussi
et savoureuse
des amandes rôties pour couronner le
tout le 25 à paraît simple à première
vue pas ce qu'il y'a pas beaucoup
d'ingrédients mais il est très complexe
en saveurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde sauf de façon classique ça se
mange avec les mains le grand plateau
servi par terre et on se soient tous
autour du plateau
quand c'est vraiment bon parlons le très
bon
pour compléter ce festin jordanien une
touche sucrée avec l'urne a fait une
pâtisserie feuilleter à base de cheveux
d'ange de blé de fromage de beurre et de
pistaches nappé de sirop à la fleur
d'oranger
on veut vraiment que les cheveux d'ange
avec le fromage absorbe le tir ou pour
moi la culture qu'il n'atteigne npa fait
la bof réconfort par excellence les
beaux gros plateau que ce soit avec du
riz un peu de viande les épices qui sont
pas nécessairement prédominante
mais qui diable y ajoute toujours une
petite touche agréable le raffinement
des épices jusqu'à la fin du repas avec
le thé sucré parfumé à la sauge commenge
c'est une expérience pic emmène aux
épices dans cette nourriture là c'est
pour réhausser le coup c'est pour vivre
une expérience très haut s'est élevé et
je pense que ce en soit ça devient alors
au delà de ses parfums et saveurs
raffinées la cuisine jordanienne se veut
généreuse et hospitalière laon de
recevoir à toute simplicité
y'a pas de flafla mais ça reste est reçu
comme une ride comme un roi
tellement qu'ils s'occupent bien toi
[Musique]